[Music]
perfume on my shirt
puts me in the past
- tough to be without but too afraid to
ask
yeah
Here I am again stuck in the middle
[Music]
Here I am again stuck in the middle hole
too young to settle down too old to be
in bars it's hard to take it easy it's
easy to be hard yeah Here I am again
stuck in the middle
Here I am again stuck in the middle
yeah I am again stuck in the middle
hmm Here I am again stuck in the middle
forgive me I am building my ship as
itself how do I become who I'd want to
be while still remaining myself
people love the me I don't know where
he's gone too tired to be famous too
vain to be unknown yeah
[Music]
Here I am again stuck in the middle Here
I am again stuck in the middle yeah I am
again stuck in the middle
Here I am again stuck in the middle home
[Music]
yeah that is insane man thinks so
beautiful thank you for that I love it
thanks for this moon it's so poignant ly
honest and vulnerable and and and raw
and I think that's really a touchdown of
your work you know my favorite line is
too tired to be famous too vain to be
unknown you know yeah it's like the
courage to you know admit that right
yeah is it almost takes um it's easier
to just admit it
yeah there's be a lot of and it takes a
lot of energy to sort of decide okay I'm
gonna share these things with people and
this list of things about myself I'm I'm
not and that takes a lot of energy to
sort of constantly be navigating and a
lot of bandwidth our founders just a
little little simpler to just be honest
and truthful yeah well I think it's
interesting in the context of you know
the evolution of your career is somebody
kind of started out in the rap world
doing rap battles you know back in high
school or it's all about fronting and
ego - you know this arc to come to this
place of just raw emotional
vulnerability you know to come to the I
mean I think of you it's interesting
looking back at the origins of how you
began with you know influences you know
coming directly from traditional rap
into this guy who got up to me feels a
lot more like Cat Stevens
you know meets in queue with his poetry
and this kind of folk sensibility
wrapped up in in pop with its roots in
hip hop and rap it said the genre thing
is a trip young because um I love a lot
of different music
is today is January what ninth night and
the last week or so I've made like four
hip hop songs in a row just straight rap
songs you know and so it's like yeah I
mean I get in the cab people are
confused yeah I get in a cab a different
City you know hey how's it going what do
you do I'm a recording artist what kind
of music do you make how do you answer
that I don't never know what to say I
say I jump around to every alcohol and
um yeah I think I'm really good at a
bunch of very good out of it I don't
know it is - yes I don't I don't feel
like I fit in one of those box yeah I
feel like I fit in all of them so how do
you follow that muse
I'm sure there's pressure you know on
you oh you need to be in this lane you
know this is what works this is what
people want I mean I know when you
played the Lions game on Thanksgiving
Day
like people hadn't seen you with the
beard yeah and now they were freaking
out because they're just to seeing you
in a certain light that was so tough at
the time but so helpful uh you know wait
a few months of hindsight so you know
first of all to answer your original
question is you really try not to pay
attention as much as you can to the
reaction to the art you know for me the
reward is in the making of the thing in
the first place and if something becomes
really popular which is happened a few
times in my career you know I made
thousands of songs but I've had like
five that have gotten like it's absurdly
popular I don't know why or how but it
happens every once in a while
but he tried just to kind of ignore that
it's almost part of my job to ignore
that and because the tendency if you pay
too much attention is to replicate or
emulate something you already did that
was quote-unquote successful so it's
just sort of leave that behind and then
listen to whatever you know yeah that
right for me I'd have some sort of
practice to be quiet
Taoiseach really helps and listen to
what comes up and me and then just
follow that the things just pop in my
head and my job is to get them recorded
and produced the way they sound in my
head and that's it if you feel like your
your your job is really to open that
channel but it's less about you that
it's that it's coming from some other
place sure I mean look we all have a ton
of thoughts that come in our head each
day and do you really get credit for the
thoughts that pop in your head it I like
to take credit something yeah I do too
you know it's like but the the honest
answer is like the song just popped in
my head
mm-hmm and I wrote it down do I get
credit for that I mean I guess in our
society way it's set up yeah I do I get
paid for and all this stuff but at the
end of the day I think it's yes more
about listening you know listening to
I'm always scared
I like superstitious all you laying in
bed at night and you know melody pops in
my head or something like that and I'm
tired like get up and put this down boom
I'm always worried that maybe it sounds
silly but I'm worried I will forget but
I'm worried that if I don't put it down
whatever is sending them to me will stop
right so given this you're not honoring
it yeah so you're not gonna pay
attention I'm gonna send this idea to
somebody else yeah that's uh that's very
similar to you know Elizabeth Gilbert I
know of her as she was this was
recommended she was like this book
called big magic okay and one of the
ideas is a great book but one of the
ideas in that book is that the idea is
all of these ideas are kind of floating
around in the clouds and you know as an
artist your job is to finally attune
that that radar that antenna so that you
can pull it down and nurture that idea
but if you don't somebody else is gonna
grab it right in its timing a lot of it
is timing right yeah so I like that idea
like oh if I don't if I don't write this
down and get it down right now like that
Muse is gonna travel elsewhere I don't
know if it's true but it might
yeah do you have like a formal writing
process like what does that look like I
do not you know I'm 30 years old I'll be
31 February 12 and I started writing my
first raps when I was 8 so I'm like 22
years into this thing and I have written
songs every which way from I written
them that night rhythm in the morning
hour I written them two beats that are
already done I've written them on the
guitar started with melody started every
every way
so there's n't one thing like oh I get
that I get the hook or the lyric no I
tried to figure this out I'll tell you
what I did a few years ago I made a
spreadsheet with what I thought were my
best songs he was like 10 songs on there
my best ones to me not the my biggest
one and so and then I tried it I made
another all these columns where I wrote
down every everything I could remember
the season the time of day I wrote it
the mood I was in what I ate that day I
want just everything I can remember to
see if there was some sort of pattern
because if if you know if if alternative
them came at 7:00 p.m. right all gonna
stop writing trying to write at 10:00
a.m. so I found no pattern other than I
think more than half of them were were
second attempts at an idea or used an
idea that had some some failed idea was
being reworked in a lot of these things
that was the only pattern right but as
far as like yeah specific process or
timing it was there was no pattern like
like having an idea but not executing on
it write it right away and letting it
marinate and you can execute on it and
failing you know sometimes we read a
song that's a bad song but has one great
line in it so then later you might be
writing a great song and you steal that
line from that bad song you just throw
that bad song away right yeah on that
idea of trying to find quietude you know
tuning out all the signals that are
coming at us it's getting harder and
harder to do that with our
phones and with the internet it's so
easy to distract ourselves with these
addictive devices that I would imagine
as an artist you have to be very
disciplined about making sure that you
carve out that special time to create
outside of that kind of influence that's
always you know kind of bearing down
upon us correct
you know for me I have a meditation
practice which is I meditate a minimum
of 20 minutes twice per day so that
route that really helps like for passing
art what is that um I usually am doing
TM yeah I've done of the pasta retreat
that was no joke man you don't want to
lose no but I it's on my to-do list for
this year that was no joke oh man ten
days ten days I which sonner did you go
- I went to one in Texas just because
that's what the way the dates worked out
and I was coming off twelve days at a
monastery where I was in solitude for
how long I was there twelve days and in
that one I was completely alone and so
there was no program whatever and so my
confidence was pretty hot my god good -
yeah I said I got this I got the real
thing was no joke man it's the sheer
physicality of it because you on a mat
on the floor sitting cross-legged for
ten hours a day for ten days I think my
back was lit up man it was no joke and
you know waking up at 4:00 a.m. you're
basically just meditating it's right
10:00 p.m. or something like that I've
heard from I've talked to a lot of
people that have that I've done those
retreats and my sense is that you get it
you get to your breaking point at like I
don't know day seven or something like
that that's when a lot of people bolt
but you gotta just stay yeah man it I
always cook because at the VIII
passionate ones you don't um there's no
talking and beyond that there's no like
they're not supposed to be any
communication she's not supposed to be
like gesturing or an even eye contact
but yeah and you're in
there's assigned mats if you will so it
is like you the people next to you are
the same every sit and you sort of make
things up about your brain at least
starts to make things up but like you
know I would I come in and like I felt
like they were my battalion you know I'm
like okay let's do this guy and then
like the dude next to me he like the
third day he didn't come back
I'm he's gone I was like and the guy
next to me I just really like there's
something about him I I liked him I was
like man in my head I was going please
do not quit man I need you hit me right
every what sorry on the last day like
let's you start talking TomTom you know
sort of have a transition period back to
getting in the real world then everyone
is kind of doing that teacher like man
you helped me so much guys like really
yeah that connection that intimacy that
that can be created without any language
or real interaction yeah I'm sure you
felt like you really knew those people
yeah I did and then sometimes I would
talk to him on the last day and
sometimes they were exactly who I
thought they were and sometimes they
were like the opposite yeah it's
fascinating I'll tell you a story from
my third day there there was a guy
sitting in front of me and he was
overweight he didn't look very healthy
he looked like sort of like a worn man
and I I'm not proud to say I felt sort
of like repulsed by this guy and every
time we'd sit and it's dead quiet in
there and you're supposed to not really
move you know and this guy would be
fidgeting you know couldn't get change
his leg whatever and I was getting so
annoyed we get to the third day and I'm
having
real tough time it hurts man your back
you know and I thinking why why did I
pick to do this is ridiculous man
and all the sort of background
negativity that's running it you kind of
got to deal with yeah when you're when
you're there and so in this particular
sit day three I'm fidgeting a lot and
we're 4550 minutes into this hour-long
said and I I'm just out of it I opened
my eyes which I'm not supposed to do and
there's this guy and he's sitting like
the gosh-darn Buddha like person showing
you what's what I start crying because I
thought you're such a you're such an
yeah I mean here's this man who he's
showing up to this theme and it's got to
be harder for him than you to sit like
this and he's showing up and you're over
here judging him about how he looks are
you fidgeting what he's such an
man and and the thing that work that
made me cry that I felt so ashamed was
because I know it's not that I know I'm
doing that all the time
you know judging people right and
judging myself and that was a bit of an
eye-opener for me I wish I could say I
don't do it at all anymore but it's it
takes time to sort of unlearn - yeah
just put it right up in your grill yeah
but meanwhile you're not really supposed
to be thinking about anything focus on
that breath economist well what got you
an equanimity man that's the goal what
got you into meditation I grew up in
Athey
I grew up it's sort of what's real is
real and was sort of a like Midwestern
Jewish pessimism about the world and
when I was 24 I saw a friend of mine who
a lot of your listeners will probably
know Watchers mean viewers isn't he his
knees Big Sean um and and Sean and I had
known each other since we were 18 you
know used to come to my house and make
music he calls my mom mom this kind of
thing and so when I'm 24 both of our
careers have sort of started and his
career is like exploding at the time for
the first time he's having his first
sort of wave and he we're both la he
says come the studio so I go a studio
meet up with him and I'm sure you and
and everyone hearing this has had a
moment where someone just lights you up
there for whatever reason being around
them makes you feel good they you might
even be around them and they leave and
you still feel good and that's what
happened that day he was just like he
was just in the good in a good place and
it was reverberating out to not just me
everyone around him so I went home and
the next day I came back to the studio I
go what's what's up with you man what's
going on here cuz he's doing I mean his
career he was like shelved for six years
I mean he's signed the Kanye for years
and years and years and years and
nothing happened and then all of a
sudden bang it was just all happening
and and he was in such a good spot with
it so all of us what song he goes you
gotta read these two books two books one
was the alchemist uh-huh and the other
was a book called ask and it is given by
Esther and Jerry Hicks
in the channel the ni saigo seems to be
working for him
I get the books man you know him that's
sort of open my whole world ignited your
whole spirit yeah and that was the
beginning and the the forward to asking
his giving was written by a guy named
Wayne Dyer dr. Wayne Dyer from Detroit I
didn't know he was from Detroit he
actually was my mom's like council high
school counts really cool yeah that's
crazy yeah Wow and so his his foreword
really resonated with me and I remember
one of the quotes ed said um I don't
think he made it up but it said when you
change the way you look at things the
things you look at change it out that
that was just so foreign to me blew your
mind blew my mind so I start youtubing
him and he has some guided meditations
so that's those were the first
meditations I ever did and then I went
into TM and then ever since man yeah
that's interesting I I would have
suspected that the path that you're on
was born more out of some of the you
know painful moments in your life but it
really sounds like it came from a pure
aspiration to just you know inhabit you
know a different level of consciousness
because you saw your friend who was
doing well
yeah and happier and I think there was
some like it's probably some jealousy
mixed into like waiting to write I want
to do that so I'm not proud of that but
I'm sure that was mixed in there as well
well let's track it back to to to
Detroit man to the beginning okay so you
started you started writing raps when
you're eight yeah in Detroit yeah so
exists like 8 mile Detroit no no I'm
from I was born in Detroit proper and I
grew up in a place called South field
sure south field borders Detroit so
everyone knows the movie eight
mm-hmm south to eight miles Detroit and
the other side
south of Detroit's 8 mile on the other
side is South field it's kind of
confusing and mouthful but other than
South field which is where I lived at
least was a was a middle sort of middle
class demo
demographically ethnically it's very
similar Detroit so it's not like
Bloomfield Hills it's not boom villian
I'm from Grosse Pointe yeah oh is that
right I was born there I mean we we
moved when I was young when I was like
seven so I can't really say I grew up
there but my parents are from Detroit
that's great you know where they went to
high school Grosse Pointe yeah is it
East Point
yeah is it Grosse Pointe North too I
don't know yeah I think it I think it
was east or south one of those on East
yeah yes so the South field is like it's
not the hood at all at least my part of
it
ethnically it's about I think 75 percent
african-american uh-huh
the young the old the younger people
like the kids tend to be even more
african-american and the sort of the
older population is more white but we
have like I had a bunch of boys on my
street we sort of played basketball
everyday we rode bikes all around had
your crew it was a magical place to grow
up man my mom still lives there and I go
back all the time I love it there mm-hmm
I love Sofia I love Detroit so that's
where it all begins
so where does the music pop and I first
started playing drums I was like in
fifth grade and I had a few older
cousins that rapped I thought they're
cool man and and a lot of my buddies
they listen to hip-hop so first hip hop
I heard was like was on TV it was like
DMX and mr. Cole and I thought and then
I later sort of got into more like
underground called it underground now
like Todd quali in
outcasts almost deaf and these kind of
things and I remember the head he wants
yeah a couple of my buddies were
intellectuals yeah they were having a
sleepover
Aaron Webster and Ronny Posey still my
buddies and for whatever reason we
decided we're gonna freestyle tonight at
this sleepover and Ronnie's house and so
we all sort of found CDs that had music
without words on it I remember I brought
a Moby CD cuz there was a track on the
end of the sea that didn't have any top
line and so I put this on we all tried
freestyling and I remember they they
sort of felt like oh that was fun and I
remember thinking I'm never gonna stop
that I'm never I'm gonna get really like
a moment I'm gonna get really good did
you have like a conscious awareness that
that was kind of a flick the switch it
wasn't even a decision I just knew I'm
really good at that and I did so now I
would practice freestyling up and at
first I'd my mom had a computer with
like a terrible microphone on the top
and I figured like on some of the old
windows there was like a voice recorder
so if I played you know music through
the computer speakers and rapped at the
same time course or make a recording
yeah there's like one of my buddies has
these like terrible things where my
voice hasn't dropped yet and I'm like he
bit so I started doing that and my mom
bought me a keyboard from Best Buy
eventually that she let me hook up to
her computer I started figuring out how
to make beats and I was stealing a lot
of software off the internet yeah and
yeah man I just kept going and like
mentioned earlier high school I used to
battle you know and which for me I was
always small in high school so I mean
basketball was everything man basketball
was everything like I the thing I wanted
more than anything was to be good at
basketball yeah I was tiny and then what
I tried real hard played good defense
but like it's not gonna happen it wasn't
gonna happen you know and so here in
this this rap
area my weakness actually before it
became my strength because I was so
unassuming I'm so small not so white
that when I would say a line that like I
get a bigger reaction right because it
was not expecting a surprising surprise
me so so that make you like I for you a
popular kid in high school then for
being able to do that
I once a I was popular by all his
friends everyone yeah it's sort of like
my relationship with genres now was the
same way I was with cliques at school
I'm cool with that everyone do I really
belong to any of them
not really I'm a floater kind of yeah
well the guy who can throw down like you
is gonna be able to ingratiate himself
with the athletes and with the stoners
and with you know pretty much every hand
crew right yeah and you know that was
really when music did begin to to deepen
me as a human to what I was doing beats
and I was selling beats to rappers in
addition to recording my own stuff and
the rappers all lived in the hood so I
would end up in these neighborhoods that
I wouldn't have otherwise been in and I
just learned a lot I had more of an
awareness for the the privilege that I
that I have and that I grew up with
uh-huh
and when I finished high school I was a
good student and I went to Duke
University after and I met a lot of kids
who didn't have that awareness and I
actually felt really bad for them he's
definitely a big cultural change yeah I
mean you sort of like trust-fund babies
and you know a lot of people might might
actually feel jealous of them I never
felt jealous of them I felt I felt sort
of sad for them because you know I only
live in this one little bubble of life
and you know since music has taken me
era take me here today's it's been a
magical way to navigate the world has
taken me all over the world well you
seem like you're like a good kid right I
mean your mom I mean education must have
been import
for you to get into Duke and you know be
a kid who's like doing the rap thing but
also getting good grades at the same
thing yeah like those two things don't
usually coexist no yeah I mean usually
just artists in general hates well I
actually didn't like school but I love
getting a's i don't know what it what
cuz there was no sort of like there was
no reward in my house and some of my
friends that get a and their mom get him
like money or something like that or and
there was no punishment either if i got
a bad grade i just i don't know i always
was like if I was in a class I just
expected to ace everything and I've
studied you know it worked hard and so
you're a Duke and you were in like a
frat right yeah she did like the full
Duke thing but you're like making beats
in your dorm room at the same time yeah
I'm trying to just visualize yeah so I I
met um I the summer before Duke I
interned at the radio station in Detroit
uh-huh so you yeah you were
collaborating with Big Sean in high
school right he was right that summer
right before we meet and I gave him a
couple beats and this kind of thing and
then I leave to go to Duke
Sean mind you had a scholarship to
Michigan State but Kanye signed I mean
he said don't go to Michigan State why
because you're gonna be a rapper date
you know don't go to college so I got a
Duke Sean stays in Detroit and I got my
little setup in my dorm room I'm making
beats I'm sending them I'm sending every
beat I make back to Sean he's the only
guy I know right you know that's like
got a record deal right but he's working
with Kanye I mean that's your he's our
Calle exactly and he's working with some
of our other buddies from Detroit I
remember how's that Duke and math
test and I was used to being like one of
the smartest kids at Duke I was like the
toughest kid I remember studying for his
math that's really hard and I got it
back and I failed it it wasn't like I
had slacked off and like man I had
worked on in study and I failed it and a
day later I got his news from Shawn that
the producers our other buddies in
Detroit Kanye was gonna sign them too
and I go man I man did I mess up
mmm that should have been me I should
have stayed in Detroit I'm over here
feeling math test and these guys nice
I'm like all right with a bunch of frat
boys yeah
Oh even think of year passes you know I
just keep making beats keep sending them
to Shawn and I make like a hundred beats
in a year send them all to him he might
use like two of them and then I had this
sort of weird idea to start start
singing my raps and where did that come
from because prior to that you weren't
singing at all no which is crazy because
you have this elegiac voice that you
know I can't yeah I can't imagine a time
in which you weren't singing thank you a
lot of practice later but um I Jack
Johnson was was blown up at a time sorta
had this like harebrained scheme to make
like a hip-hop Jack Johnson band right
where would Hannah and Jack Johnson was
huge at Duke yeah you know he's huge
everywhere in time and yeah and so it
seemed and uh so I had this idea of like
having acoustic guitars J Dilla drums I
would wrap and and rap and likes her
singing and there was another guy at our
school erik whole gist he would sing he
was like a real singer and and then so i
started his band mike posner in the
brain trust and we start putting stuff
out and really what happened was the two
guys in the band quit Eric was the real
singer
and I love Eric Tuesday he has a another
band called Delta ray that he started
after and they're very wildly successful
now and Jeff oh he bring his guitar back
and so I like man I gotta start singing
the stuff and what was interesting to me
was as I was such a big hip-hop fan and
I had never heard a rapper I never heard
a singer sing the way I really wanted to
hear a singer sing as a hip-hop fan so
an example is like um my first popular
song is this one cooler than me yeah and
it has the complex rhymes in it multi
syllabic rice which I never heard
singers use so I'll show you what I mean
I say you got design or shade just to
hide your face so not only do shades and
face right but designer and hide your
Roger also and that to me which is
freaking cool like I never had a singer
do that yeah well when you sing it you
don't immediately think hip-hop but when
you deconstruct it you can see it yeah
but like a hip-hop fan we hear that
right you know so you're like you're
bending the genre I mean it's really
bending bending the genre from the
beginning is what cracks it open for you
it was a weird sort of like it took 12
years so at this point I'm 20 I made
music all this all these time it wasn't
all 20 that I stumbled on this thing
that was influenced by others but was
unmistakably mine hmm and I knew right
away everyone's reaction was different
people were singing the song all over
Duke campus and Brice you make these
demos right and they're getting played
at the parties they play at the prize
people and and I didn't go to the
parties because I was recording in my
dorm and the only time is loud in dorms
the only time you could really record
when everyone else goes out 11 p.m. to
2:15 am so that's that was your vocals
window that's what my vocals went down
my buddies would come back maybe like
man they play cooler than me at the
party everyone knew it which that never
happened to me then my mom calls me she
goes
I like this song cooler than me really I
love my mom to death she's an honest
woman she never told me she liked any of
my stuff before always supported me
bought me instruments pay for lessons
she never said I like this personally
she says she like courting me then Big
Sean called me he goes Cort Amin's like
a hit song man like a we talking about
me yeah if both your mom and Big Sean
like it exactly that's what I was
thinking and so then that it just sort
of started from there yeah and what's
what's unique and cool and kind of of
the moment of that time is the fact that
you end up releasing this song on iTunes
you yeah right because that was there
was no Spotify you couldn't as a
consumer just upload your music onto the
internet to distribute it right but you
kind of found this loophole correct and
and this was at a time when music was
being pirated at a very high rate and
music industry was really in trouble and
I knew better than anything when I had
the Duke Internet we were stealing
everything you know and so it was just
like full Napster era or a little bit
was a few years after losing BitTorrent
stew Kranthi and LimeWire yeah all that
kind of stuff and so typically if you
made a what they call mixtapes which was
like a free album a lot of times rappers
before they make their album they make a
mixtape okay which would include some
original stuff and we'll also include
them rapping over other people's beats
now I made a mixtape and my mixtape was
hosted by Don Cannon who did all the the
biggest mixtapes okay I had this very
legitimate cosign from Don Cannon and
typically you'd put this thing out on a
website called datpiff.com
and there was like a Z share link you
click the Z shot already lost yeah it's
like it was his
really confusing thing there were ads
all over it trying to trick you to click
other and then like you had to navigate
your way to a place where you'd actually
right click and hit like save target
eyes and it would download and I knew I
could get my stuff in those places on
that website and stuff but what but I
also remember my friends tell me these
these white girls at Duke know the words
to this song so I'm thinking I gotta I
gotta get in a place where they they can
get it too because I know they're not
always he shared they're not on datpiff
so I haven't was easier I'm gonna that
pith but in addition I found his
loophole with iTunes U which was set up
for professors to post their lectures
you know if you're a professor at Duke
you can do a lecture on a topic and
anyone from all over the country can get
in the cool thing about iTunes U at that
time was it was free mm-hmm yeah you
could download lectures from all of
these colleges correct yeah I think does
it still exist I think so I was sort of
transformed in some ways and so the
loophole was I found the guy who ran
iTunes U for Duke and I called him up
and that we still text every once in
awhile and I find out he's from he's
from Southfield Michigan oh man it's
like so lonely yes so he goes I heard he
goes I'll put your home on there he goes
up done that before and it's true I
wasn't the first guy to do it so he put
my alma on there and now my stuff is on
iTunes but it's free now that's
important because we weren't buying
Kanye's albums
we weren't buying new pays out we
weren't buying jay-z we were stealing
although yeah so I knew no one's gonna
pay for my album because they don't know
who the heck I am so it's important is
free but it's also in this safe spot mmm
iTunes and so um I started a Facebook
group I got all my buddies to invite all
their friends all my high school friends
at different colleges and before I knew
it I was I was being asked to come to
every college man come play come play
this fraternity this thing and I'd get
there in there and everyone knew my
stuff yeah
so it's this interesting combination of
artistry and entrepreneurship like yeah
did you know learning how to like market
your own goofy run a deal you know like
DIY yeah yeah that's cool so so is that
how it got like how did it get to
because the next phase is super
interesting like how did it get to you
know all these record labels and jay-z
yeah there's people I record labels that
are looking for this sort of thing
they're looking for artists that while
they're doing a show and everyone knows
the words to their stuff and they're not
signed right so a few you know some
people spotted me some ANR's and some
managers reaching out and it's a small
industry so sort of one label is Hamas
on too late was then you can kind of go
to a third one guy hey they're gonna
offer me a deal do you want to have a
meeting type of thing
and so yeah my stuff started to catch on
and I was taking these meetings I'm in
my junior year at Duke I'm flying in New
York I mean with Craig and Julie at
Atlantic you know meeting with Barry
Weiss at RCA and I'm going back to do
again I'm in finals week you know and
I'm writing this paper and my manager
calls me and he says you gotta go back
to New York I can't go back to New York
what I need to do is finish his paper
meet cuz okay
I'm behind the eight ball a little bit
here man and he goes yeah go back to New
York jay-z wants to meet you
I wrote jay-z didn't wanna meet me man
don't mess with me he goes jay-z wants
to meet you
I go okay book the fly and I believed I
didn't believe I thought I was gonna go
and they would say hey we're sorry he's
busy today you're gonna meet with
someone so that's why I actually thought
that happens all the time like if you've
been around entertainment that's stuck
it goes that way yeah
not and I would it's yeah that's what I
expected man so I didn't tell any
friends you know and I get on the plane
I go to to New York do you think sorry
to interrupt you but do you think that
impetus like I have to go even though I
have a final was in part informed by
this sense that you had made this
mistake in going to Duke while Big Sean
and those other guys were getting signed
like you didn't want to miss another
perhaps yeah I had a deal with myself in
those years which was if there's any
scent on the trail you gotta go so there
were times where you know like the first
time I was supposed to meet what can and
did my mixtape I drove to Atlanta and he
something got messed up like the guy
connecting us and he was busy and I went
there for no reason but I had to deal
with myself there was sent on the trail
you got to go and what's the ambition
level look like at this point then or
now bad hi well I tell you what change
it for me was was knowing Sean you know
cuz I met Sean and then Sean really got
his deal done with Kanye and he was gone
in the studio with Pharrell he's gone in
the studio with the dream he was meeting
Madonna and this was a guy that I used
to free start with you know we go back
and forth in his hip-hop I always
thought I was better than him
not just you know I thought better than
everyone and so this thing that seems so
far-fetched before was just I knew
what's gonna happen now I go Sean did it
I'm next
it's happening you know it's I just knew
yeah and but I tell him all the time and
it he really changed my life twice once
by just living his life in that way show
me what was really possible and then I
again when you get tell me read those
books right yeah and and you know by
living it yeah in the studio that day
and so J so you're on you go to New York
yeah and Seana oh he helped out somebody
a year before the jay-z meeting we're in
Detroit and Kanye's playing going the
dark tour okay
and Shawn gets like guest listed 20
tickets so it's like all of our buddies
are there man
Shawn brings all of us backstage and
meet Kanye and then it's like three
months later Shawn calls me up and he
goes Calle is playing MSG tonight you
want to come
jay-z supposed to be there I say I do
ramen Michigan right phone is silent msg
Madison Square yeah phone is silent for
like 10 seconds my gosh probably Booker
was a play he goes he goes yeah yeah you
should ah so we go there I go to pick up
the tickets at will call
I'm gonna get back to the next meeting I
got I go to MSG I go to will call say
hey I'm Mike Posner tickets supposed to
be here and they go we have no tickets
for you Dane are you sure
Michael maybe Mike open no tickets for
you I call Sean I go man there's no
tickets here for me he goes okay just
meet me at the studio then I'm at the
studio at Kanye I go upgrade yeah like
thank God there are no tickets oh we go
to a studio it gives me a dress he meets
us downstairs and always in these nicer
studios there's a lounge which is like a
room for the managers to wait while arts
meeting so he goes just wait in the
lounge so he goes in the studio and you
can hear the music they're playing and I
hear one of the songs I did was Sean
playing whoa
and I know Kanye West is listening to
this track
who knows that I produced I sang the
chorus on and Seana rap done and I I'm
freaking out because I know if he likes
this thing this could change my life
like for real for real like so a song is
I see a bunch of people walk by the
lounge towards the elevator I go I guess
we're leaving now so I walk I follow him
out and Shawn is there Kanye's there
Shawn goes Calle this is Mike Posner he
made the song they I just played you
kind guys oh cool gives me a fist bite
and then there's another silence five
seconds ten seconds and very
courageously I ask did you like it
it kind of goes No
oh no he goes it he goes maybe maybe it
could be for Lupe it's not right for
Shawn and then he said one of the
coolest analogies or he goes I'm sorry
Shawn bumped it you said it I had to
spike it meaning like he played it you
asked me I had to tell you the truth I'm
like and then I'm thinking like how do
you think of that that could assist you
appreciate the honesty like on one level
didn't feel I want to be very clear it
did not feel rude at all
uh-huh because you meet too many people
and they all manage blow smoke up yeah
yeah it was just honest have you Jonas
have you and it helped me it helped me
because I knew in my heart I had better
stuff in me uh-huh
and so we got in this elevator and all I
wanted to do is make music I didn't want
to quit I wanted to make more and that
six months pass I keep doing my thing I
keep plugging the stuff starts to catch
on now I'm back in now I'm in the office
with jay-z right all right well before
you get into that two things okay first
have you run into Kanye since
yeah to talk about this yeah yeah I'll
get to that all right today so we'll put
we'll hit that later secondly I think it
goes to that thing you were talking
about about showing up like it could
have what if he had liked it that could
have changed your life and the fact that
he didn't and he told you still held
tremendous value in pushing you to do
and be better for sure for sure but that
wouldn't have happened had you not
bought a ticket and gotten on the plane
thinking you're going to a concert but
being led into you know this other
situation that you could have never
heard I sent on the trail hmm and so I
so now now I'm in finals week uh-huh
six months later and eight I don't
remember eight months later and I'm in
jay-z's office I got my laptop I'm
fumbling with the aux cable I get that
thing in there I'm nervous
I play cooler than me and jay-z goes
like this he'll just like squish his
face yeah just like in a way that you're
not sure if he likes it no I you know
he's into I knew he loved it I knew he
loved it and we had this incredible
meeting here I felt like he really
understood me I was there like two hours
which in hindsight I'm like that was
ridiculous and I'm about to leave and I
just had this inkling and go cap play
one more song he says yeah so
my laptop back in I play him who knows
same song and he went nuts he goes - he
goes I can't believe you almost left
without playing this for me he got you
know don't ever forget to play that song
so I go back this is the same one kind
of in like same something I go back to
do I'm back in the library
try to finish this paper in a moment of
procrastination I opened up my email
there is an offer for a record deal from
rock nation now I end up signing with a
different label but why two reasons one
that the actual deal was was better
mm-hmm
significantly and secondly Shawn hadn't
blown up yet so I look at my buddy who
assigned to an artist as opposed to
being signed to a major record label and
I thought man I don't know is do the
artists do they do anything or do they
only care about themselves so I'll sort
of hesitant now what I learned was later
if you're signing to artists and you
sort of get it's like this on any label
you get the ball rolling yourself they
can add a lot of kerosene to the fire
you know if your sign of jay-z and you
start blowing up you might do a feature
on your second single you know and then
paint kabane but it's a little bit of
wait and see
yeah but I hadn't it's like that with
any label but I just hadn't seen it yet
all I knew was my buddy had been signed
to three years and nothing had really
happened yet so I signed with a
different label and weari release cooler
than me a remix of cooler than me Big
Sean was on the original cooler than me
and this song sort of explodes and I go
to the European Music Awards in Madrid
Spain and I see Don see it was like
Kanye's right-hand man
and he's the man I could don't what he
goes have you seen Kanye I go no I go I
he probably doesn't remember me and he
goes all on me in a DC so I look Calle
he introduced me and he didn't remember
me I got to just can't tell him the
story I just told you and one of the
things he said even before I said the
story was ah Mike Posner because I
really liked your music and I knew I had
done my job after I got out of that
elevator I went and I worked and I
continued to get better and it felt
really good that's pretty cool
full circle and so much yeah I mean
sometimes the the the failure in the
moment is not really a failure it's it's
a step on the path to success right
right I mean you got to be able to hear
that kind of constructive criticism
without taking it personally or letting
it deflate you but as somebody who I
mean you're somebody who I get the sense
fully owned the fact that this was gonna
be your path had a deep profound knowing
that somehow it was gonna work out for
you so when you're that rooted and
committed I don't know if you were
obsessed but you were definitely you
know full bore 100% headed in that
direction yeah when you're in that place
you're in a better situation to hear
that kind of feedback without without it
getting you derailed correct correct so
this song blows up and does that change
your life in some ways yes and others no
and I'll tell you what I mean by that
it changed the things I was doing so I'm
playing concerts much more often for
many more people I'm making more money
I'm sort of parading around the world
taking my shirt off at shows and
unfortunately what I realized
and it's such a gift to sort of fall
into this kind of quote success at the
age I was at which was like 23 the ways
it didn't change my life was it didn't
make me any happier it didn't make me
any more comfortable in my own skin and
it didn't clear up any of the
insecurities I had with myself and what
was especially disillusioning about that
was I thought it would I thought when I
get these accomplish these things I'll
feel content in myself to a point where
I'll actually be nicer to other people
but I just wasn't well that's a shared
delusion
that's an epidemic and a culture right
yeah I just get this if I can get this
status or this thing or this job or this
relationship or this bank account then
that's gonna solve my problems and I can
and I can relax and collect yeah I'm
okay with myself and I don't know that
um you can just hear two guys talking
about that and believe them cuz I didn't
you know I had to learn that myself and
that's why I say it was a blessing a
gift you know I feel that my audience
has gifted me the opportunity to explore
what life's about when you stop chasing
shiny things right well the interesting
thing is you had the awareness the
conscious awareness to understand that
the chasing was not going to resolve the
dilemma because I think most people who
find themselves in this situation which
is a quality problem to have hey let's
be clear yeah
then perpetuate the delusion by saying
all right well I just need one more hit
correct I mean one more how neat well I
got this nice house but if I just get
the bigger house like they'll chase that
to the grave great so to get off the
train is
something that eludes most people and
it's difficult to do so why do you think
you were able to do that I think I'm
doing it still to be clear you know
there's a there's definitely some part
of me percentage that still does that
still wants everyone to like me and it's
upset when they don't and wants to so
you how many years are not enlightened
you're not an enlightened being you know
look you're human so yeah but I think
that person I know for sure honesty
about is refreshing the percentage of
that is lower each year I think you know
it used to be a hundred percent you know
I I didn't have any awareness of it it
just it was me you know there was no
part of me that was looking at this
looking at this a you know objectively
now I'd say I'd hope it's like under 50%
of like why I do what I do well you have
this huge hit and it puts you on the map
but then you have kind of a fallow
period where you're trying to make you
know more hits thinking it's gonna be
easy because your first one was huge
so you've had the ups and the downs you
know what it's like to be in both of
those places and it reminds me of that
thing that Jim Carrey has said which is
something along the lines of like I wish
everyone could be famous so they could
realize like it's not the solution to
what ails us or what we're truly looking
that's a great line yeah that's a great
line he's right yeah he's right plus the
irony the added irony of the song that
makes you famous
cooler than me is this about you not
being cool correct then it makes you
cool it happened again yeah and I happen
again you know so my second big hit that
I sing was a was about the fall from
Fame which I thought was was pretty
interesting you know I took a pill in
Ibiza yes I took a pill in Ibiza is
about what happens like you're a one-hit
wonder and then what happens with that
really that story's not so well
documented this is a line in there it
says um
you know I'm just a singer who already
blew a shot I get along with old-timers
cuz my name is a reminder of a pop song
people forgot and the song time gods
could I mean but then there's something
about this song that ironically gives me
another shot while setting aside you
know the melody and the lyricism and the
kind of you know beautiful technical
aspects of what makes that a great song
great pop song
it's the honesty and the vulnerability
that I think allows people to connect
with your humanity
thank you you know again and that's what
we were talking about at the outset I
mean that's a that's a theme that runs
through your best work
yeah and and to me that's not a
departure from hip-hop authenticity and
hip-hop matters a lot you know when you
when you listen if you think about your
favorite rappers they tend to be people
that you believe what they say like
they're not making up a story you know
whether it be jay-z jay-z says he never
lies in songs and that's probably true
and it's cool cuz you there's an
authenticity to it it their stories
don't resemble my story mm-hmm
but I've always tried to maintain that
that feeling that what I'm saying is is
true you know not as some pieces where
they're like completely fiction and I
think it's pretty obvious when it is but
that yeah how do you swear there's a lot
of fronting and hip-hop too right
there's a lot of chest-pounding there is
but if you think about your favorite
guys you know I shouldn't say laughs I
think about my favorite guys which are
who I mean jay-z Kanye West no no top
five is right now it's time for
dangerous 103,000
you know J Cole you know Kendrick these
are guys that are they're authentic you
know isn't
and if they're saying if they're saying
they drive a certain car they probably
actually have that car you know those
guys that's funny which is not the case
right and and and this saw how many
years in between the two heads 2010 and
like five or five years right yeah so
you get that the the first hit you make
it big suddenly you're touring you're
traveling people know your name all that
stuff you get the dope house in the dope
car was there a little bit of like now I
am gonna be cool
like I'm gonna play this out like let's
see what this experience is like yeah I
mean I guess I was there doing what I
thought I was supposed to do which which
is sort of I'm sort of ashamed about now
a lot of like um womanizing um this is
like wasting money on like clothes and
shoes and stuff like I had shoes I
didn't even know I any remember I had
and a certain point just couldn't
justify it anymore
you know I just like how do I have all
this stuff and like how do I have 200
pairs of shoes or something ridiculous
and there's someone within a mile from
here that has none you know so I just I
don't know I I I knew that making more
more attention from the opposite sex
more fame I knew I wasn't gonna change
my experience of life did you have like
a bottoming out moment with that or was
it just sort of a slowly arising
awareness that this wasn't what gonna
work slowly a rising slowly arising in I
remember I I bought a van on I think if
I'm on Craigslist
and added like sort of bent sheets in
the back that fold out to a bed and a
little closet and I just put the stuff
in that could fit in there we donated
the rest I just drove away from all your
I join my house huh so yeah like I just
left and I went to the I went to Utah
and I always wanted to see if I could be
happy without all my and I found
you yeah so I should probably stop
orienting myself orienting my life with
with money fame notoriety attention from
the opposite sex as my North Star uh-huh
at the same time you were you're still
writing songs but they just weren't
connecting in the same way yeah I never
stopped writing songs you know a lot of
the sort of a gap in my career from 2010
my first album - my second 2016 but I
made two albums in that time it was just
that because my career had slowed up so
much that my career was really
considered over by my record thereby
just sort of everyone in the English
music industry yeah I was considered a
one-hit wonder a good songwriter hire
him to come in if if you if you want to
hit single or something like that but
him singing is that's sort of done and
so my I was making these sounds but they
weren't being released and I hope to one
day sort of figure out the legalities
and and get those out there Wow
yeah it feels like it seems as if in
that period after that hit when you're
trying to you know replicate that or
just you know in this presumption that
you're gonna be able to you know create
more and more hits you're fighting this
growing sense that you are a one-hit
wonder and it's only when you make total
peace with that and then do it in a
public way that everything then shifts
again correct correct is like you can't
have what's next until you're okay with
what
here now yeah and during that period of
time is this when the kind of spiritual
growth is starting to take root like
what are you doing correct yes I started
meditating and this book I'm asking it
is given it changed my life is about
sort of a wacky thing that people have a
lot of opinions about by believing the
law of attraction which is you sort of
get what you think about so if I'm
thinking about you know my success is
coming then my success is coming if I'm
thinking about it's not here yet I'm
gonna get more of it's not here yet so
there's this subtle shift in the in the
thinking acceptance and freeing yourself
from expectations yeah it's just sort of
like um re brainwashing myself it really
was like a brainwashing where I had to
train my mind to think of my career
myself differently than everyone else
did you know cuz everyone else thought
my thing was done and each day I would
journal I was sometimes write the same
sentence over and over and over again
and I just got myself to I take walks
where I'm repeating the same thing
almost like a mantra in my head like I
will accomplish this and eventually I
started to really believe that and maybe
maybe it's happenstance I don't know I
can't say for sure I don't have a
double-blind study but I know that I got
my own internal dialogue to a point
where just like the first time where I
knew that was gonna happen cuz Sean did
it I knew I was coming back yeah I knew
my everything you know it was gonna be
the one no because I thought it wouldn't
be the one because it has a drug
reference in the title and the first
line so I'm thinking they're probably
gonna play that on the radio yeah but I
didn't know I I I knew was a good song
when I wrote it yeah I liked it right
away
so this song it gets it gets remixed
right and that was the one that goes
bananas yeah and this song has been
played like a billion I'm Nessen
exaggeration like a billion times on
Spotify right it's like something like
but one of the top couple most stream
songs I'm up in the history of the
platform yeah at some point was like six
months ago is number ten all-time
all-time probably and past but how do
things yeah that is insane it's insane
it's crazy like how do you even process
that oh no I guess I don't really like
goose it started out at the beginning
try not to really write you know cuz my
job isn't to make another B's it's just
to make whatever pops up next yeah well
I feel like there's this interesting I
don't know if it's a trend but this wave
of artists musical artists who are kind
of redefining what it means to be
prolific and for lack of a better word
like cool like the old trope of rock and
roll star parties you know ends up in
the grave too soon you know the Janis
Joplin kind of scenario is outdated and
now what's really interesting our people
that are not only producing amazing art
but doing it from a place of elevated
consciousness like I see you as somebody
you're you're like a spiritual warrior
you're on this spiritual journey and the
more you kind of raise your conscious
awareness the better your work is and
there's an infectious kind of spirit
that emanates out from you perhaps in
the same way that you felt from Big Sean
when the hopes of making that and I see
this you know with people like yourself
but you know like in cue is somebody
who's very much like that and I know is
your boy but there's a lot of people now
and and I think the public is embracing
that and saying this is this is cool
like look at these guys like they've
gone through hard things and they're not
just checking out with drugs
alcohol and you know how many chicks
they can sleep with or whatever like
they're coming from it from from you
know this higher plane I that's my this
is so nice you to say that thank you is
that's my aim you know if I could if I
could be that for other people if I give
that gift that Sean gave to me that day
that's like my highest it's not the
mission I know on your website you have
like you can click on the mission tab
and it's like one sentence yeah it's um
to enjoy my life and help others enjoy
their and in the meantime be as kind to
other people as possible
that's pretty salty it's my mission yeah
you know and I had this crazy moment
with Brom dust you know Rhonda of course
so a buddy of mine his mother was dying
and she had a relationship with around
us they were friends Lisa Skype and they
had a trip plan she died and my buddy
says I still want to go we go with me to
Hawaii tohe why we go go to Maui and we
roll up on his house and it is like just
you know beautiful and they let us in
and they supposed to sit in the living
room and he comes in on his electric
chair and he's had a stroke and he
looked at us with these big old eyes
that just said I love you we could have
been serial killers he listed and he
said a bunch of words I heard him say
before but some of you you you felt it
was the energy you felt it I don't know
how to explain it other than it was a
palpable physical feeling and I left I
walked out of his house he he talked to
us for like 45 minutes and he goes okay
time for you to go
and healthy boundaries and I just want
to stress it wasn't anything he said it
was all stuff I'd heard him say before
there's almost like recycled speeches it
was him and we walked out door closed
door and I like I killed over I he told
us
you're walking around all day and you're
choosing and categorizing what to love
and what not to love you know I like
this I don't like this all day you're
doing that he causes too much work just
love everything look he goes see the see
my friend told me we mean loved
everything and he he sent me a dirty
carpet I framed it there it is I love
that carpet and he has a puja table
right and so he's got like Gandhi and
Maharaji and you know all these Saints
right and then he kept keeps up then it
was a picture like a George Bush now he
keeps Donald Trump because he doesn't
like George Bush and Donald Trump but he
loves them and I just walk out the house
they this is a whole different way to be
in the world yeah that is that's that's
heavy the oneness like be just
unconditional love for all and the
interconnectedness of everything correct
and I thought I didn't feel like I met
some guy something like date here I felt
like I met a guy who did the work as I
do has been meditating it you know he's
done the work for last however many
years 40 50 and I just made a deal with
myself like that's that's what I want to
be to other people what else do I have
to do you know so what are you if I
could light someone up like that yeah
that's that's what I wanted how do you
practice that how do you combat your own
internal you know presets to override
you know whatever judgments you have in
order to kind of occupy that space well
we keep going back to meditation that
helps you know yoga helps
sighs helps cuz he's sort of like
cleared things out right yeah it's like
yeah you know you finished some hard
workouts like that's sort of like a
reset right
it's your back to zero and then you
could create your own story so for me
that that involves like a lot of
studying you know whether is you know
listen to a lot of these guys lectures
like ROM das or and the watts or Abraham
Hicks and Eckhart Tolle I just try to
like brainwash myself with that stuff
and I'm always I'm always trying to
listen to to that stuff recently I've
been um I just started this thing
because I realized I'm always listening
to like someone someone's lecture or
like someone's like affirmations like
when I'm going to bed I'm like it on a
clip or and I thought I should make one
for myself and so I just recorded some
for myself that are like tailor-made for
me like I know that I know that things I
need to work on like you know that I
still care too much about what other
people think about me and you know and I
know I can get petulant and frustrated
and and sort of petty at times so I set
up I sort of made my own recordings and
I'm excited about sort of brain washing
myself with those I like that yeah
that's cool what do they say can you
tell me are they just for you um I think
I'll probably release him at some point
you know yeah they just sort of like
work myself up into a frenzy units and
I'm saying in first person it's like I
am you know I'm right where I'm supposed
to be you know I had to live my whole
life to get right here the the past is
is not a real thing that exists only in
my head and it and it really has no
bearing on me right now what's moving my
life forward is my mood and my vibration
in this moment and that's it and I'm
here and I'm supposed to be here and I'm
a good person and I'm happy and I'm
loving you know these sort of things and
it go and sometimes I'm like yelling
so excited you notice it's cool it's
beautiful when I think of you and I kind
of look at how you live your life and
what you do you're an artist who who
whose work extends beyond just music
like I feel like your canvas or your
template is your life and the way that
you share it like there's the songs and
there's the concerts and the
performances but the open way in which
you share your life experience is like a
larger you know it's like expanding the
aperture on on what your artistic
expression is with this canvas of your
life and how you're and how you're
living it I just want to say thank you
because these are these are things that
matter to me and I look at that the same
way like my I do feel like it's not just
my music is my life my Gandhi said okay
you got a story your guy went up to him
on a train once and he goes can I have a
quote he was a writer kind of quote for
my newspaper gave a message and he wrote
down my life is my message hmm it's like
all my all my decisions in this creation
my whole life that is my big piece of
art like and I'm adding a stroke or
taking a stroke away every day so I just
want to thank you it's it's cool for me
to be seeing the way I see myself so I I
just want thank you for that you're
welcome I mean you you have such a
charming beautiful like childlike nature
to yourself you know what I mean it's
like easy to be with you and I can't
help but compare that to the life of
your friend Avicii I did I wash his
documentary the other day and was very
moved by by it and and there's plenty of
have you seen it have you watched no I
don't know you didn't want to watch it I
don't know if I can yeah but I think
what what I took away from it is
somebody who
extremely gifted and also you know like
just kind of an introverted beautiful
giving dude you know who just had this
facility for music that was unbelievable
and what honey was yeah and and I'm not
like steeped in DJ culture like I don't
know that much about it but you can't I
don't think you really can know how good
he was unless you worked when I'm like I
did because it Tennessee and I'm sure
some of these guys do they go up there
and they hit play or whatever but he
what it his genius was in the studio
he's right in these songs you know and
he's making all the music on his
computer right and his sense of melody I
mean the Swedes are known for their what
so my friend made fun of me because I
did a 23andme and I have like point one
percent Scandinavian they think oh
there's where your hits are but his
melodies were just ridiculous the
melodies of his drops and then he would
write the melodies of the songs too and
he was annoying in the studio cuz he
every little note I had to be exactly
right he's changing it complete
perfectionist yes and they have all
these people like Wyclef Jean and Chris
Martin and all these people are like oh
my god this you have no idea how
talented this guy is like so supremely
talented it's all in his head he's got
it perfect in his mind and the process
is just bringing that to life and trying
to get other people to understand what
yeah I do Express but in that journey
you know his his like his arc to
superstardom was so rapid and he was
suddenly surrounded by this
infrastructure of people that there was
this whole machine behind what he does
and he was powerless to get it to stop
and throughout the movie he's like I
have so much anxiety I got a stop we got
a can't like warning sign warning sign
warning sign warning sign and still it
was so difficult for him to extricate
himself from that and I think most
people would think about scenario and
say well he should have decide better
around him or why couldn't he just say
no and take a break and the truth is
it's more complicated than that it's
these weren't bad people that were
surrounding him and nobody when their
job yeah they're doing their job and
they're not telling him look you can't
cancel they're just saying well if you
do this is gonna happen it was very
realistic portrait of what it must be
like to be caught caught in the middle
you know in that situation and he did
take breaks and the movie kind of
concludes with him on this island and
you think it's going to be all good
because he is he finally finished all
the shows I'm not going to tour anymore
and you think he's going to find the
peace that he's looking for
and yet the depression or whatever you
know kind of mental disposition that he
was harboring he still couldn't overcome
and I think it's informative for anybody
but especially someone like yourself
who's been in that situation been out of
it is back in it you know what do you
take away as somebody who was his friend
and who collaborated with him and knew
him quite well like what do you take
away from how he lived his life and how
does that inform how you make decisions
the first thing I take away is actually
not from his life from his death and I
don't think he's particular to his death
but anytime someone close to us goes the
first thing it does is reminds us we're
next we're gonna go too and people don't
like to think about this one of the
reasons is painful and so this his death
reframed my life in that I
the time is now you know the we all got
a list of things that we want to do when
we're done doing what we have to do you
can't wait you know it's like my dad is
dead now he can't do any more tim is
dead now now Mac is dead now too I know
one day I will be dead as well before
that day I need to live my life I can't
wait till tomorrow or next week this is
it and I have one of those
infrastructures as well you know around
me and it's set up to maximize profits
so it's like you have a song okay you
need a tour as much as you can sell as
many songs as we can and there's no one
on the team there's no like palliative
member of the team right going let's do
X amount less shows to to make sure mike
is good and yeah that's my job so um I
think one of the reasons Jeff connected
us was you know part tim's passing is
one of the big reasons i'm walking
across america this coming year is you
know this was someone wanted to outdo
any i got it that's the first thing I
thought may I do that walk I
could do that walk before it's too late
will you wait for is your life so now I
gotta have some hard conversations
I caught I had to meet with my band say
hey guys we need touring this year so
you got a whole tour cuz you have an
album coming out in like a week yeah I'm
crying week so I'm supposed to do the
tour options to do all the late-night TV
oh so they're on a book tour right but
that's that's protocol it's the way it
goes yeah yeah hard talk with my manager
hey man I'm actually gonna make zero
dollars next year which means you're
gonna make zero dollars how'd that go
it's a tough conversation for him you
know at first now I call a day later I
go where we out with this man cuz I are
you upset with me he goes look man I
know you're making a life decision not a
career decision and I support you so II
got my back you know at the end of the
day but yeah it's hard it's hard cuz are
all these people are are reminding you
exactly like you said but but you can
miss this opportunity what if what if
we're Coachella wants to book you you
know oh no I gotta do I gotta do this
man this is it I wrote the other day
it's a lot to unpack you know um it's a
lot to unpack I can't put my life on one
track you know people say I'm giving up
a year of my life to do the walk
I say I'm taking one back that's how I
feel it's my life it's my life okay
I can't I can't do what everyone else
thinks I'm supposed to do whatever - yes
your life if you're not gonna take
control of your life worth what where
you're at right now then somebody else
will and you like you said you've got an
infrastructure that would be more than
happy to take take the reins on that
correct you know and it's it's so it's
got to be even harder for you to put the
brakes on and say no I'm gonna do this
other thing so we should just say for
people that are listening or watching
March first
you're gonna walk across America yeah
it's gonna take you like the better part
of a year to do it maybe a year who
knows yeah where does this like why this
like what is this about man we are we
are that that list the same way a song
pops in my head I know I got it right it
alright I'm this pop my head no I got to
do got to do it just it's instinctual
I know I I know I want to do it I know
you know I don't know why I want to
alright I'm not making that call I'm not
I'm not deciding what's calling to me
I'm just I'm just listening and is the
idea to kind of create a community
experience out of doing this
sharing it yeah having people join you
they play music along the way yeah it's
like I ain't a nyan I know what's gonna
happen if I you know sit in the studio
make a almond tour I don't know what's
gonna happen I'm walking across Arizona
and 100 degree weather yeah but you're
gonna have so many people coming out to
walk with you yeah well I can't wait you
know and I just got to a place where
like I said Tim Pass and I just sort of
tired of listening to all these great
podcasts that you and P and others do
and reading these books about all these
great individuals and in and not doing
those things myself I want to like it's
all that I'm marketing to myself like I
want to be the person that I think is
awesome like if I was not me and I heard
my music I would think is awesome
obviously I'm biased but if I if I was
if I was not me and I was looking at
Mike Posner and he was doing his career
and then he said you know what I'll walk
across America like me personally I
would think that guy is freaking amazing
I'm trying to make myself someone I'll
be proud of you know and then that
target moves because I become that
person you know next year I'll be that
guy that I'm like dreaming of so it's
it's really cool I have another like oh
I said um I don't know what I'll do what
it's done when it's done
hopefully I touch a life maybe you could
be one I'm not walking to find I'm not
walking to show people who I am I'm
walking to find out who I'll become
yeah and and as somebody who's whose
life is your art you have to live that
life in order to have something to say
and to express it's I'm like there's no
way I'm gonna do this thing and not
learn oh no way not learn acquiesced is
the the unknown like the absolute
question mark of like what's gonna
happen because stuff will happen yeah
gonna be this crazy adventure yeah I've
just had some like emails of people who
have done this and they go say things
like nothing will be the same after this
or they'll say things like like at some
point on this journey you will come
to face with the deepest depths of your
soul but now they go but don't worry
about that yet you know it's like you
know what whether it's that or even 1%
of that I'm gonna I'm gonna learn more
I'll have more on my palate than I do
now a year from now of course I'm I'm
not retiring you know for music at all
it's like I'm even more committed to
going out there diving back into life
and bringing that back to my music I
feel the deeper the human the deeper the
songs and on on the surface this may
look like me like attempting to drop out
or escape from the world it's actually
the opposite I feel like when I'm
sitting like in a nice house and I get
on the tour bus and everyone on the tour
bus works for me I feel like that's a
departure from reality that's not real
life I want to die I think I want to
walk through all the smallest towns in
Indiana and listen to people and listen
in the meantime while I'm walking to all
the greatest albums ever made that I
haven't gotten to yet and come back and
and put all that into my music well I
know it's right because you just
literally came alive talking about this
you know I think and the irony is that
is that this is probably gonna be the
best marketing tool for the album by
like like you said like you know like
hey you do Fallon you do this you go on
this late-night show you then you do
this is the tour that you do you're
doing something completely different but
I think that's interesting and I think
people are going to be interested in
following that journey I think it's just
gonna create a groundswell of awareness
all right what you do it could not tell
maybe not who cares the point is like it
doesn't matter exactly you know and I
you know won't be honest - there is some
part of me that has thought about that
and hopes that happens like yeah like
this will be my biggest tour of all time
and screw you label look I did it my way
and now I'm a big star
what is the label
actually having guy had a harder
conversation than your manager yeah I
think he had to tell them so I haven't
gotten any calls yeah so March 1 but
you're starting you're starting on the
East Coast right do you have the route
mapped out I was I will in the next few
days all right
and so because this won't go up for a
little bit but yeah so right now I'm
looking probably in New Jersey I've been
looking at it's not decided so if anyone
one wants to join or follow along they
can follow me on social on Instagram
that's really where I am I don't you
really do Twitter um but I'm looking at
Asbury Park I'm a Springsteen fan so I
think it'd be cool to go you gotta start
with your feet in the ocean
yes exactly well my freakin coal plant
put my whole body I love that hold water
me neither cold water yeah I love cold
water I get in there I was it have a
house in northern Michigan ha ha he was
up there where another Michigan well I
would get tweet details like a little
secret like a tiny tide don't want it to
like blow up knocking on your door but
it's an hour away from Traverse City
uh-huh yeah yeah I was just up there in
December and I got in the water and it
was real cold but I loved it it's like
it's like 20 coffees to me yeah yeah man
so that'll that'll be cool and I my my
anyone is sort of invited to join you
know with some caveats you know I'm
gonna be walking like 20 miles a day as
I ramp up into this are you gonna do it
with a backpack or no like how are you
gonna know handle a magic using this
probably in the most pretentious way and
that I'll have an RV that goes ahead of
me got a one-person with me that allows
me to do a couple of things one allows
me to go faster ranks I'm not carrying
as much stuff to I can bring more stuff
like a guitar and a keyboard uh-huh
whereas if I'm like pushing a cart most
people don't do a backpack um some
people start with the back because it's
very romantic
but most people end up pushing a cart
because it's more practical so yeah I
just be able to take more stuff and play
music and have like my mom can come out
for a day type what type I think I do
plan on doing like at least two weeks of
this thing with the cart like I went up
there so we'll see so in prompt I know -
your oh yeah oh yeah yeah tons oh yes
your advice - about like what Karen
blister prevention man yeah cuz with
things like this it's the tiny things
it's the details that can derail you if
you have the wrong pair of socks or
right you know your shoes get wet and
then you get a big blister and then you
can't walk we can talk more about that
all these but yeah yeah you don't want
to make sure taking care of that but you
know if you have an RV full of stuff
you're gonna be alright
you know I think the thing is you're
gonna be excited in the beginning and
you're gonna want to like walk a little
bit further then you probably should
each day and so did err on the side of
less is more until you acclimate and get
used to it yeah great advice yeah
and then you'll kind of it you'll build
into it over time but I'm excited for
you man me too gonna be cool I could
just see you like you're coming up on
some little town and there's like a
little theater that no one ever uses and
you're like hey man could we use that
tonight you know and just shout out on
Instagram yes if people show up or
whatever and yes way and we could to
know some people we call those ninja
shows and that was invented by a woman
named Amanda Palmer do you know man of
course
unbelievable human and thinker and
artist and excuse me and she made up
this concept of the ninja show which is
when her shows would sell out another
good problem to have
she would feel bad for people that
couldn't get tickets
so before her show she would tweet hey
I'm gonna be at this corner with my
ukulele at seven o'clock come and I'm
gonna play uh-huh and she just goes show
up and play and I heard I read her book
me I was like I gotta do that this is so
of course I've done probably 40 of those
then I've played at like the Grand
Canyon where like five people have shown
up and I've played at the school like
University of Dayton where I tweeted
Hammond beer in like an hour right in
like two thousand people show oh it's so
cool
and it's really fun because most shows
are set up to keep you as separate from
the audience as possible you think about
the the stage itself puts you higher
there's usually a barricade with
security in between the stage and the
barricade and even the word fans short
for fanatic sort of like stay away from
those yeah sort of um yeah
it um categorize danger as dangerous
yeah and that's how I thought about my
audience until I did started doing ninja
shows because I was I play my guitar and
then I meet him after and it just people
like you and me like we both have
artists that we love and we listen to it
like for whatever reason i'm i'm that
artist for them which is a so cool and I
know what that's like because I have
artists like that you know one of them's
Calle what is okay and music is about
connection correct
and yeah I just stopped thinking about
these you know that saying like I never
want to be in a club that I was allowed
into it's sort of like that where there
was earlier in my life more but it's the
underlying sense of unworthiness like
there must be something wrong with you
if you like me this much but no there's
nothing wrong with me or them you know
this is they connect my music yeah so
that was it was really cool doing those
shows and I'm excited about doing tons
more of them are you gonna dot do you
should document you're gonna have like a
documentary career with you because this
idea of going across America and
connecting with this country I think
it'd be made our fall i I
and honestly have enough on my plate
right now logistically figuring out how
me and one person with me are gonna do
this thing it's only one other person it
will be with me and Noelle cycle won't
be the same person the whole way but my
plan is sort of announced this thing and
if anyone wants to shoot me they're
welcome to but I don't really want to be
like executive producer you know I don't
want to kick you out of being present
for the yes which is the whole point and
I don't want to be managing a lot of
people yeah I want to walk if you you're
friends with Jay Jenkins probably aren't
you no but I want to be oh really
yeah I can't believe you don't know him
I would have thought you guys I know
ovens right yeah but his experience from
that bike ride you should you should
definitely connect I have a ready book
either I heard it's incredible it's
great I heard his writing is he's a
beautiful writer he's great right yeah
you should definitely read that book I'm
amazed that you guys aren't connected
I'm happy to connect you please yeah
very he'll help me a lot cool so let's
wrap this up
if we could close it down with a few
words of wisdom for somebody who's out
there who aspires to give voice to their
creative Muse perhaps somebody who's a
little frustrated or stymied doesn't
know how to take that first step
yeah you know what is what are some
inspiration or some tools that you use
that have been helpful in bringing
bringing truth to your expression being
an artist is a really simple job and
this goes for any medium writer painter
musician your jaw
is to create the art that you want to be
in the world the art that you want to
exist and how do you define art and
artists anyone doing some creative you
know I think no but yeah you're asking
about someone who's looking for their
muse and what gets in the way of the
muse is when we start worrying about
what other people will think even one
extra person is - money if I think about
what rich will he like this song it will
mess my process up all I can do is
create the stuff that I want to be
created the stuff I want to exist
it's a beautiful job you get to tailor
make things for you beautiful things
that are that are made to your exact
preferences and no one else can do it
except you and so it's just very simple
that coming back to that has helped me
every album hmm you know and I think I
heard it I don't I didn't make that up I
heard it from Maria Pope Eva from brain
pink like frame packings I'll just just
make what you want to be made that's it
you know so we could we could zoom out
just do what you want to be done your
life that's it is your life is your
creation go get it no one else can do it
for you if you don't do that thing it
just won't happen you know if you don't
write that song that song won't get
written it no one else could do it for
you
it sounds so simple it is simple it is
simple it's easy to lose track of that
but I think it is pretty simple to come
back to that yeah I've told B I've told
big name artists that they're in the
throes of an album and they're confused
they have too many songs she's like what
do you like what are you trying I just
tell them that and they go it's like
they took a took a dip in the cold lake
and I
and it's for myself - yeah being honest
with yourself about who you are what it
is that you want to say I think it
requires a level of like self
integration self understanding that
comes with the meditation and all these
other practices that you've been doing
they don't hurt you're sure
well uh you're beautiful man mike posner
thank you you are two men and I didn't
even get to as you any question no it's
not about me it's about you today
I love everything that you are and - and
I wish you only the best most incredible
experience on this walk thanks I see you
at the end with all the I don't know man
I think I might come I might have to
come and join you fleu sorry since we're
invited it's uh it sounds amazing
you are super inviting and your
beautiful soul and I appreciate your art
your artistry and the spirit with which
you share your your gift because you are
a gifted man thank you
and the way in which you're so you're so
free with this gift with humanity I
think is is something really special so
thanks for coming and sharing I
appreciate that
what else we have to do I don't know
that's it man life is short brother Han
cool so if people want to connect with
you just you're easy to find on the
internet I was like oh I thought Mike
posed marry POS and like Nancy er
Spotify Instagram your website where my
composing they're dying huh
you're gonna have the map there right
I'll have the map and I would say like
if people really want to join up
probably the best place is Instagram I
think I'll be most sort of active and
perhaps it will pull my website probably
pull from there um and also yeah it'd be
ready if we really want to walk to you
know like if you can't walk a mile don't
come try walk with me you know
this is for real this is real this is
for real
and did some other things out I told I
have in my sight you know I said I'm not
this isn't like a catered event either
you know it's like if you want to come
from morning the day you gotta figure
that out on your own right you're you
carry your burden on another now your
food or whatever and are all safe you
want to walk with me um no drugs or
alcohol
you know we rollin into as guests into
tiny towns and I got no interest in sort
of babysitting drunk people or high
people clean living clean living right
do this rich reimagining the Rockstar
life there you go bro well you're gonna
have to come back when the walk is done
and tell me about it that would be so
cool man cool maybe like the next day
yeah a straight Kier dude today she is
calling forget it
but if I get here later on the ways for
sure man - that's right pass right by
here I think I'll be crying
that's good man people have cried on
this show all right dude he's much loved
peace
[Music]